[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme au sahel
l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime
on parle de jay liste on parle de gens
qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe d'un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un big mac sont
embrigadés ils ont été séduits ils ont
été manipulés et d'autres qui agissent
de manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours mon
adversaire même si je méprise totalement
son idéologie comme c'est le cas pour
séguiniste
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de la formation avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 22 mars des
limites poutine dénonce la position
conflictuelle de l'union européenne à
l'égard de la russie un ralentissement
volontaire du processus d'homologation
de spoutnik vedan lieu réaction de
moscou au lendemain des propos de
thierry breton le commissaire européen
au marché intérieur a estimé que
l'europe n'aurait absolument pas besoin
du vaccin russe
des experts de l'agencé européenne du
médicament sont en tout cas attendu en
russie le 10 avril
[Musique]
autrement je suis manifestations contre
un projet de loi renforçant les pouvoirs
de la police a dégénéré à bristol dans
l'ouest du pays
plusieurs policiers ont été blessés des
véhicules incendiés des dégradations
commises dont le commissariat de la
ville
la ministre de l'intérieur dénonce des
scènes inacceptable
[Musique]
un procès symbolique pour des actes dont
les images avaient fait le tour du monde
c'était le 1er décembre 2018
dix personnes sont jugés jusqu'à
vendredi pour le saccage de l'arc de
triomphe
pendant une manifestation de gilet jaune
des scènes d'insurrection mais dont les
principaux instigateurs n'ont jamais été
identifiés
[Musique]
l'europe n'a absolument pas besoin de
spoutnik vais les mots sont du
commissaire européen au marché intérieur
tir et thierry breton mis sur les
vaccins disponibles pour atteindre
l'immunité collective en europe d'ici au
14 juillet a pas besoin du spoutnik vais
donc les russes auraient un mal fou à
fabriquer rajoute le commissaire
européen qui laisse entendre que je
serais moscou qui aurait besoin de
l'aide de l'europe
étrange déclaration dénonce des mires
poutine la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine claireaux le président du
conseil européen charles michel a estimé
que la russie était responsable du
mauvais état de ses relations avec
l'union européenne tout en appelant
moscou à faire des efforts sur les
droits humains et la mise en oeuvre des
accords de minsk en ukraine en réponse
vladimir poutine a regretté de façon
générale la position conflictuelle de
l'union européenne envers la russie
et justement s'il ya bien un domaine en
ce moment ont constaté des crispations
c'est bien la vaccination
dimanche soir thierry breton jugeait que
l'union européenne n'avait pas besoin du
vaccin russe et ce malgré la pénurie de
vaccins constatée sur le vieux continent
plats d'hiver poutine a réagi un peu
plus tôt dans la journée en se demandant
quelles étaient les réelles motivations
du commissaire européen aux pêcheurs
comme on vient de le rapporter à
l'instant un des responsables de la
commission européenne a déclaré nous
n'avons pas besoin de soutenir v4 scarna
spoutnik les mines ou une déclaration
chez 30
nous n'imposons rien à personne et en
europe nombreux sont ceux qui ne savent
pas que la réussit un déposé il ya
l'autre tendance elle demande
d'enregistrement de son vaccin auprès de
l'alliance européenne des médicaments
cela a été fait comme tatiana golikova a
rapporté ce matin le 21 janvier 2021
tuer ce n'est que le 4 mars que nous
avons été informés du fait que notre
demande commencer à être examinées
je tiens à dire à cet égard comme je
viens de l'indiquer que nous n'imposons
rien à personne mais quand nous
entendons des représentants officiels
faire de telles déclarations
une question s'impose quels intérêts en
france et représentent de telles
personnes
les intérêts de sociétés pharmaceutiques
ou ceux des citoyens rage des pays
européens
qu'est-ce qu'ils font du lobbying il
n'empêche que le spoutnik v est
actuellement en train d'être examinés en
vue de son autorisation de mise sur le
marché européen
dans ce cadre l'équipe d'experts de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments est
d'ailleurs attendu en russie le 10 avril
prochain
quoi qu'il en soit vladimir poutine l'a
rappelé la russie ne force personne à
accepter ces vaccins 55 pays dans le
monde font déjà confiance à spoutnik v
et à ce jour aucun effet secondaire
sérieux n'a été constaté à la suite de
son administration alors l'europe
peut-elle vraiment se passer du vexant
russe spoutnik v comme l'affirment
thierry breton quelle attitude eu lieu
face à la pénurie doit-elle peut-elle
bloqué les exportations c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir avec nos
invités
[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec un
loïc et mme prud'homme députés avaient
fini 3e circonscription de gironde 1
florian philippot président des patries
bottes des patriotes et enfin françois
pupponi député modem 8e circonscription
du val d'oise bonsoir à tous les trois
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on l'a entendu
thierry breton très sûr de lui un qui
affirme ne pas avoir besoin du spoutnik
v cette déclaration elle nous a surpris
et choqué florian philippon fait de
l'idéologie politique sur les vaccins ou
c'est d'un tout autre ordre
honnêtement ça ne m'a pas surpris
puisque on sait que l'union européenne
depuis des années et hystériquement
engagé dans une croisade contre la
russie en fait la demande d'ailleurs
deux intérêts américains c'était une
très mauvaise chose pour la politique
française que je pense qu'il aurait
intérêt à un dialogue constructif avec
la russie du point de vue des intérêts
français
ah mais ça on est donc le cédant
toulouse mène donc y compris dans ce
domaine là donc voilà ils font là ils
font de la politique ce qui est ce qui
est presque ce que sont que la france
devra retirer que les français devraient
exiger de leur gouvernance et que la
france devrait s'occuper elle même de
ses affaires parce que l'union
européenne est un véritable fiasco sur
cette affaire du coc vide le vaccin
n'est pas déjà avant c'était au tout
début d'épidémie elle qui nous avait
demandé laissé grand ouvert nos
frontières c'est elle qui a acheté du
rem désir pour un milliard d'euros en
octobre alors qu'on savait que ça
servait à rien à voir c'était dangereux
donc tout ça il faudrait une enquête
d'ailleurs un peu sérieuse
voilà et donc l'union européenne c'est
le seul point positif de cette crise
c'est que je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
français maintenant qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'il vaut mieux être un pays
indépendant et souverain et qu'il faut
leurs écrits quitter cette structure au
plus vite alors loïc prud'hommes c'est
vrai comme le précise ici le spoutnik
véhicules utilisés dans plein de pays à
l'argentine le mexique plusieurs pays
d'orient la slovaquie et la hongrie a
même qui s'affranchissent des règles de
l'europe
vladimir poutine on l'a entendu qui
s'interroge sur les entreprises
pharmaceutiques les lobbys les intérêts
quel est votre avis sur cette question à
ce qu'on est en train de faire la
politique du lobbying on ne défend pas
spécialement les intérêts des citoyens
européens sont cette affaire clairement
la question se pose quand l'on voit
effectivement le fiasco de la stratégie
d'approvisionnement en vaccins de
l'union européenne et et les paroles de
thierry breton on voit qu'il aurait été
bien inspiré d'avoir un petit peu de
modestie et puis de sa de s'occuper
vraiment de l'intérêt sanitaire des
populations avant toute chose parce que
la question aussi c'est sur ces labos
pharmaceutiques ayant effectivement on
peut vraiment se poser la question s'ils
défendent pas plutôt ses intérêts là
c'est que il faut rappeler aussi que
tous ces vaccins aujourd'hui que
monsieur thierry breton semble défendre
ceux qui sont produits par les labos
pharmaceutiques notamment américains et
ou autres c'est qu'ils ont été mis sur
orbite par une manne financière
importante de nos pays de l'union
européenne mis en orbite mis sur orbite
par la recherche publique qui les a
lancés qui a permis d'aboutir dans les
recherches mais mis sur orbite et aussi
par des financements publics pour
commencer à les produire et en fait ces
vaccins que l'on n'a même pas on les a
déjà payé une fois et il faudrait les
payer une deuxième fois alors que on en
manque et qui en seraient bien inspirés
d'aller regarder effectivement comment
on peut disposer d'autres sources de
production et comment aujourd'hui on
peut aborder cette question on ne peut
plus l'aborder sans parler de la
question des licences libres puisque
aujourd'hui 50% des capacités de
production mondiale de vaccins ne sont
pas utilisés du fait de discours comme
celui de monsieur breton on a besoin on
a besoin de personne d'autre on se
débrouille très bien
on n'a pas besoin des autres et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'en plus le vaccin
est très mal répartis au niveau mondial
alors que c'est une pandémie mondiale
les pays riches en disposent un petit
peu les pays pauvres pas du tout et donc
c'est aussi cette question là qui est
posée par cette polémique entre la
russie et l'union européenne déclenchée
par des propos à mon sens irresponsable
de monsieur breton alors peut-être que
l'ong à la mère qu'elle est en train de
réaliser qu'elle s'est fait un peu avoir
sur ce coup là parce qu'elle semble pas
être vraiment d'accord avec
le commissaire européen je vous propose
d'écouter la chancelière allemande
en ce qui concerne le vaccin russe je
suis d'avis que tout vaccin autorisé par
l'agencé européenne du médicament
devrait être utilisée dans l'union
européenne
je préférerais une commande de l'union
européenne mais si celle ci
n'intervenait pas alors l'allemagne
devrait agir pour elle même et c'est ce
que nous ferions françois pupponi c'est
étonnant cette déclaration denguélé
merkel si pro-européenne collective
comme elle l'a montré dès le début ça
dit quoi
mais quand l'europe fait une erreur mais
les pays reprenne un peu leur pouvoir la
déclaration du commissaire breton est
absurde on a besoin de tous les vaccins
et si un vaccin qui s'appelle pratique v
qui est efficace et qu'on peut obtenir
il faut le faire on voit bien qu'on a du
mal à vacciner massivement la population
en france
astrazeneca à des difficultés de
livraison s'il ya une solution
alternative
il faut surtout pas s'en priver et
sincèrement je pense que la déclaration
n'était pas celle qu'il fallait et est
ce que l'allemagne qui est aussi
confrontée à une reprise de du virus
actuellement c'est très bien qu'il faut
accélérer la vaccination et que si un
moment l'europe se bloque parce qu'elle
veut faire de la diplomatie vaccinale ce
qui serait absurde il faudra passer
outre et trouver des vaccins là où il a
dès lors qu'ils sont efficaces
alors on verra bien ce que diront les
spécialistes européens le 10 avril à
moscou
mais si effectivement le vaccin et est
validée et bien il faudra en acheter
massivement pour accélérer le processus
de vaccination dans notre pays un
florian philippot je m'entretenais tout
simplement avec des jeunes à dubaï qui
m'expliquait 1 28 et 25 ans qu'ils
avaient reçu leur deuxième dose de
biotech aide ses soeurs sont même la
demande et on les appelle tout
simplement voilà c'est source sûre
puisque les élus en ligne moi même on
peut comprendre peut-être l'agacement
d'une angela merkel qui voit sur son
tarmac allemand décoller des avions
remplis de bio and take me rappelle que
c'est un chercheur d'origine turque un
migrant qui était en allemagne qui a
trouvé ce vaccin
l'europe fès s'est fait avoir l'europe
est dans la main des lobbies de toutes
façons on des puissances financières sur
tous les sujets c'est vrai pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est vrai
dans beaucoup de domaines son histoire
c'est cela c'est de plus en plus la
scène un pouvoir qui n'est pas élu pas
démocratique responsables devant
personne donc ça conduit naturellement à
ce genre de dérive puisque moi je suis
pour la vraie liberté vaccinale je pense
qu'une stratégie sanitaire ça peut pas
être qu'un vaccin d'ailleurs on voit que
l'union européenne aussi enfin vers en
émaneront sont bien d'accord avec ça
bloque les traitements h r block la
prévention pas cher etc etc
il impose même l'austérité à l'hôpital
ce qui nous a mis dans une situation
très compliquée mais ce moment d'olive
on a fermé 110 millions 25 ans en france
une antenne ayant demandé à de
nombreuses reprises donc si vous voulez
moi je suis pas surpris ce que dit
madame merkel sait que l
quand il ya un souci elle sait qu' il ya
un pays qu'elle a un pays qui s'appelle
l'allemagne et qu' il ya quelque chose
qui s'appelle l'intérêt national
en france ça n'est pas possible d'avoir
ce discours enfoncerait tellement dans
la religion européiste qu' on ne met
jamais l'intérêt national avant tout
jamais on est capable de dire à la
france va reprendre sa souveraineté et
faire telle ou telle chose
jamais jamais vous l'entendez macron
dire cela jamais absolument jamais et
alors que l'allemagne évidemment ne voit
l'europe qui à travers les intérêts
allemands germanique bien compris et je
ne lui en veux pas je pense que c'est
tout à fait normal si j'en veux aux
dirigeants français de ne jamais
défendre nos intérêts et nous enfermer
dans cette prison est un fiasco dans la
main des lobbys des conflits d'intérêts
de la corruption et de l'inefficacité
est ce que vous parler de la france de
l'ornière
filippo c'est vrai que la france les
vaccins arrivent au compte gouttes ont
fait un petit état des lieux tout de
suite regardé sur
cet écran qui va apparaître donc les
livraisons les chiffres parlent d'eux
mêmes faiseurs prévu 9 millions reçu 5 6
millions moderne a prévu 1.5 millions
reçu 600 milles astrazeneca prévu 6
millions 1,6 million comment vous à
l'elysée ces chiffres loïc prud'hommes
c'est retards intempestifs en france
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure en fait c'est que la politique
européenne elle et elle est vraiment
enfermé dans une logique libérale mais
qu'ils n'arrivent même pas à maîtriser
puisqu'ils se sont mis dans la main de
contrats opaques croyants sur parole des
laboratoires qui n'ont de cesse que de
faire des profits sur sur notre dos donc
ça ça ne fonctionne pas et on le voit
ici puisque les promesses ne sont pas
tenues l'argent et bien contractualiser
mais on ne verra pas le début du goût
d'une seringue et d'un vaccin donc c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
maintenant il ça suffit cette affaire ça
suffit il y à 50% des capacités de
production mondiales qui sont inutilisés
je vous rappelle notamment que dans
cette affaire du spoutnik et il ya un
contrat qui va être passée avec l'inde
pour poteau pour produire 400 millions
de doses de sportive et c'est de ça dont
il faut que l'on parle maintenant c'est
mettons tous ces vaccins en licence
libre
mais toutes les capacités de production
mondiale pour faire face aux besoins que
nous avons sur l'échelle de la planète
parce que cette pandémie on ne s'en
tirera pas et madame merkel ferait bien
de s'en souvenir on ne s'en tirera pas
en jouant perso dans son coin et en
essayant de ramener des doses vers soi
parce que tout ça circule aujourd'hui
dans sur la planète et que c'est
ensemble et c'est donc avec une
stratégie vaccinale mondiale c'est ce
qu'ils appellent l' oms de ses voeux
c'est ce que simple une centaine de pays
ont demandé c'est là que la france aussi
a voté contre et peut-être qu'elle était
inspiré par thierry breton sur la levée
des brevets pour qu'on puisse produire
partout sur la planète et qu'on puisse
fournir tous les gens qui en ont besoin
y compris ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de payer des sommes faramineuses aux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
effectivement tout ça sent le conflit
d'intérêts
ap l'année c'est vraiment déplorable que
nos stratégies vaccinales que la santé
de nos concitoyens et concitoyennes soit
juste juste heureux jouer à la roulette
russe d'une d'un capitalisme hyper
financiarisé qui ne sait pas aujourd'hui
faire face à la pandémie
avant nous faire rêver françois pupponi
on va regarder à l'échelle européenne
maintenant l'astra zeneca lens est
encore plus accablant comme comme
constat je vous laisse regarder les
chiffres 1 100 millions commandés au
premier trimestre 30 millions livrer 300
millions commandés au premier semestre
100 millions livret est ce qu'il ne faut
pas revoir la liste tout simplement des
producteurs tout simplement renégocier
les contrats si c'est possible en tout
cas l'exigé je crois qu'il faut déjà
sanctionné ceux qui ne respectent pas
les contrats c'est le cas nasri n'est
qu'à la réforme européenne la tête de la
commission l'a dit ils y apprennent le
respect des contrats il faut qu'ils
aient en tuant des sanctions s'ils ne le
font pas et si on s'aperçoit qu'à sera
zeneca comme les autres ne sont pas en
capacité de respecter les engagements
il faut aller chercher des vaccins
ailleurs dit comme à l'autre il ya le
vaccin chinois également il ne faut pas
hésiter à le faire la situation est trop
grave
on voit bien fait je rappelle que si on
veut une immunité collective en france
il faut qu'on soit sur environ 500000
vaccin jours et on est loin loin loin du
compte et donc on voit très bien qu'il
faut la stratégique était celle de
l'europe aujourd'hui patauge un peu et
patine un peu compte tenu de l'absence
de livraison en fonction des contrats
qui ont été passés il faut donc trouver
des vaccins ailleurs ce que dira tous
les jours astrazeneca s'est pas bien ce
que vous faites on vous sanctionnez on
peut le comprendre mais ça ne fait pas
venir plus de vaccins donc il faut
trouver de l'extérieur et sincèrement le
spoutnik v comme d'autres vaccins
peuvent être une solution complémentaire
et puis il ya les pays que qui sont
capables d'acheter des vaccins
et puis à ceux qui ne sont pas capables
d'acheter vaccins qui n'ont pas les
moyens qu'il faudra aussi aider donc il
faut augmenter la production de vaccins
d'autres dans le monde et ça c'est
indispensable urgent parce que sinon
nous n'arriverons jamais à la limite et
que l'équipe qui est indispensable pour
enrayer la pandémie
florian philippot tout le monde le sait
ceux qui ont le plus de vaccins c'est
ceux aussi qui ont payé
plus chère en israël et les états unis
est ce qu'il aurait fallu avoir ce
pragmatisme à l'échelle européenne
badge façon on n'a pas l'union
européenne n'a pas donné d'informations
très précises puisque vous savez que
tous ces contrats ont été négociés dans
une opacité et où l'on table à tel point
que même nos ministres sont à peine au
courant voire pas au courant de ce qui a
été négocié et enfin tout ça est tout à
fait lamentable et l'union européenne
dit je j'économise l'argent des
contribuables face à l'a pas empêché de
faire un chèque d'un milliard d'euros
pour acheter je le disais du rem désir
au mois d'octobre au moment où l'om est
baptisé déjà que ça serve à rien donc si
vous voulez que tout ça est un argument
bidon mais je pense que ça sent beaucoup
plus effectivement conflit d'intérêt
et puis je voudrais quand même dire que
derrière tout ça il ya le refus de
réfléchir sur un traitement qui est
aussi un énorme problème est lui en
pleine rue un rôle fondamental dans
cette affaire en refusant des choses sur
les lieux avec tin et c'est alors que
beaucoup l'étude le magazine capital a
recensé 40 études internationales dont à
l'as rome devises et qui ont montré
l'efficacité de ce traitement qu'il
coûte que 8 euros eon la vie c'est son
problème c'est qu'il n'est plus temps et
puis l'union peine et est aussi depuis
ce 17 mars la déposer une initiative
législative européenne en ce sens
elle nous embarque vers son passeport
sanitaires et ça moi je ne veux pas et
j'ai pas envie que ce soit une structure
supranationale qui décide à la place du
peuple souverain
une rupture quand même pour nos libertés
pour l'égalité entre les citoyens
avec cet affreux passeport sanitaire
louis il ya plein de raisons de se
défier de l'union européenne et
d'entamer un grand débat national sur le
fait de ce qu'on doit pas à imiter des
anglais les sortir de ce machin avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
loïc prud'hommes pour revenir déjà sur
vos propos la france clairement intérêt
aujourd'hui à déclencher sa procédure
d'urgence au sein de l'union européenne
pour acheter de son propre chef d'autres
vaccins que ceux commandé par l'union
européenne ce que menace de faire
finalement l'allemagne angela merkel je
ne suis pas pour qu'on s'aligne sur les
positions
lippert égoïste et libérale de
l'allemagne moi ce que je vous dis c'est
que la france devrait plutôt jouer de
son influence pour demander la levée des
brevets pour que effectivement on puisse
produire en nombre
à tout le moins pour l'union européenne
pour déjà pour commencer mais ça c'est
une évidence mais on peut pas en quoi la
jouer perso je me permets de vous couper
parce que l'allemagne quand même comme
je vous le disais et productrice a
trouvé le vaccin va il avait été égoïste
peut-être qu'ils auraient pu le garder
pour eux nous on n'a pas trouvé le
vaccin les français mais ça c'est encore
une autre question c'est comment on
arrive à ce fiasco dans la recherche
française où on n'est pas fichu de
trouver ni un vaccin ni traitement ni
même de réouvrir en l'espace d'un an les
milliers de lits qui aujourd'hui nous
nous font défaut et font que nos proches
et nos anciens sont en train de de
passer de vie à trépas pour des défauts
de stratégie sanitaire dans notre pays
c'est quand même assez hallucinant en
2021 et moi ça me met très en colère
mais c'est pas la position de la france
pour moi la position de la france serait
effectivement de pouvoir participer à ce
que ces vaccins soient produits en grand
nombre sur le territoire national bien
évidemment si on avait fait ce que l'on
réclame depuis des mois à la france
insoumise réquisitionner les moyens de
production nationaux pour produire des
vaccins mais pour cela il faut lever les
brevets il faut que tout ça soit d'un
domaine public qui est aujourd'hui
nécessaire
l'allemagne ne réglera pas ses problèmes
seul pas plus qu israël pas plus que
ceux qui ont les moyens de se payer
j'allais dire en premium des des vaccins
alors que les autres n'ont pas et vont
continuer à diffuser la pandémie mais
tout ça est éteint et en tout on ne peut
pas effectivement centre est la question
que sur des vaccins mais c'est celle de
de la production de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française qui a montré à
quel point pour verser des dividendes
notamment sanofi a laissé à laisser
passer toute recherche sur des remèdes
ou sur des vaccins mais qui espère bien
en tirer les fruits financier pendant
que nous on en meurt donc tout ça est
absolument insupportable aujourd'hui et
je pense qu'on serait bien inspiré de
reprendre la place qui est la nôtre dans
le concert mondial en exigeant que enfin
le bien commun soient défendues françois
pupponi sur ce débat de lever des
brevets sur les vaccins je pense que
vraiment la france n'aura pas le choix
comme des autres pays européens
s'il fait toute la stratégie française
c'est de dire on évite le confinement au
maximum mais on va vacciner et on savait
très bien que c'était le mois d'avril
qui devait être le moment où le
haxhi nation elle est rentrée en plein
régime parce qu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on a vacciné d'abord les
personnes âgées puis des personnes à
risque que c'est compliqué qu'on est
loin de l'immunité collective
donc il faut vraiment qu un moment au
mois d'avril on soit capable de passer
un niveau de vaccination important mais
si nous n'avons pas les doses la
question se posera si un moment on
constate que l'europe n'est pas capable
de nous livrer les doses parce que les
fabricants de vaccins ne sont pas
capables de livrer l'europe
alors oui toute façon vous savez
l'allemagne commence à le faire d'autres
pays comme la hongrie l'on fait déjà et
ils tous les pays européens se poseront
la question si roman l'europe est
défaillante chacun reprendra son droit
essaiera de sauver sa propre population
c'est sûrement la pire des solutions
mais on pourra pas reprocher à un goût
amer parce qu'on perd en france est de
dire devant le constat d'échec pour nous
obliger de prendre des décisions et moi
va jouer la déclaration de gm laquelle
aujourd'hui est très révélatrice en
disant voilà on laisse encore un peu de
chance à l'europe de pouvoir régler la
situation si l on n'est pas capables
chacun reprendra sa liberté d'action
comme le veut le droit aux pinces d'or
ce domaine là allant de la fin florian
philippot bas le mot de la fin
moi je trouve que quand dire que l'on va
sauver son peuple c'est la pire des
solutions sur ça bizarre ce que vient de
dire monsieur pupponi non ça s'appelle
prendre ses responsabilités un
gouvernement français il est là pour
défendre les intérêts français
d'ailleurs c'est ce désir incroyable que
ça nous paraissent incroyables alors que
ces cas de tous les pays du monde où
tout le monde c'est comme ça ce qui
n'empêche pas des coopérations
internationales qui doivent être les
plus fructueuses et amicale possible
enfin bon le boulet ans vont quand même
le président l'armée française devrait
se souvenir qu'il est quand même en
charge des intérêts français plutôt que
de rêver d'europe en permanence et et de
nous produire donc ici des cauchemars
c'est tout moi je ne pense qu'il faut
quitter cette structure est qu'il faut
avoir l'honnêteté d'avoir le ce débat
devant les français à un référendum
merci à tous les 3 loïc peu d'hommes
florian philippot et françois pupponi
d'avoir été avec mon direct sur rt
france et on vient d'en parler
d'astrazeneca qui se trouve dans le
viseur de l'union européenne accusée de
ne pas honorer
ces contrats avec un bruxelles la
présidente de la commission européenne a
menacé hier le groupe anglo-suédois
d'interdire des exportations de ces roms
vers les pays qui ne pratiquent pas la
réprise réciprocité londres qui se sont
visés a jugé cet avertissement de
contre-productif les explications de
françois tissier beach il est toujours
difficile de garder de bonnes relations
après une rupture londres et bruxelles
l'ont prouvé une nouvelle fois ce week
end après une passe d'armes par médias
interposés en cause le retard dans la
livraison de doses du groupe
pharmaceutique suédo britannique dans le
contrat signé avec astrazeneca
bruxelles devait recevoir 180 millions
de doses au deuxième trimestre de cette
année
résultat l'europe n'aura que 70 millions
même constat pour le premier trimestre
ou lieu devrait avoir reçu au total
quelques 30 millions de doses
c'est trois fois moins que prévu par le
groupe pharmaceutique
du coup la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen menace
toutes les options sont sur la table
nous avons l'option d'interdire toute
exportation prévu
c'est le message que nous passons à
astrazeneca respecter votre contrat avec
l'europe avant de commencer à livrer
d'autres pays
une menace rapidement commenté autres
manches longues souligne la nature
collaborative de la production de
vaccins impliquant plusieurs pays et
prévient l'union européenne c'est que le
reste du monde regarde la façon dont la
commission se comporte six des contrats
et des engagements sont rompues ce
serait très dommageable pour un bloc
commercial qui se targue de respecter la
loi
ce serait contre-productif cela
compromettrait non seulement les chances
de leurs citoyens d'avoir un programme
de vaccination appropriée mais aussi de
nombreux autres pays dans le monde et
nuirait à la réputation de lieu
le laboratoire suédo britannique avait
annoncé la plus grande capacité mondiale
pour son vaccin tablant sur trois
milliards de doses prévues cette année
soit près du double des chiffres
annoncés par pfizer bio ntech un volume
de production assurée par une vingtaine
de partenaires répartis dans plus de 15
pays à travers le monde pour les retards
de livraison
ateras zeneca évoque jeu si des
restrictions d'exportation
pour faire simple confronté à
d'importants problèmes de production en
europe
le laboratoire voudrait faire venir des
vaccins produits hors sol européen
mais on ne le laisserai pas faire un
argument apparemment loin d'être
suffisant pour bruxelles restez avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la manifestation contre un
projet de loi renforçant les pouvoirs de
la police qui a dégénéré hier à bristol
dans l'ouest de l'angleterre
la ministre de l'intérieur dénonce des
scènes inacceptable et puis non
viendront assure un procès symbolique
qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui celui de 10
personnes jugées pour le saccage de
l'arc de triomphe
pendant une manifestation de gilet jaune
le 1er décembre 2018
[Musique]
gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas un
mouvement politique le peuple français
était arrivé au bout de ce qu'il pouvait
supporter il ya énormément de problèmes
en france comment se fait-il tourner les
impôts les plus élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits les plus importants
et comment se fait-il que nous dans les
campagnes on n'est même plus de service
public quand je vois l'état du pays
aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés c'est impossible
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage montagnes de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez
direction à présent le sud ouest de
l'angleterre bristol où une
manifestation a dégénéré hier les
protestataires s'étaient réunis pour
dénoncer un projet de loi visant à
limiter les rassemblements des heurts
ont éclaté avec les forces de l'ordre
deux policiers ont été hospitalisés ont
fait le point avec leïla sarraf à
bristol des centaines de personnes
manifestent contre un projet de loi qui
prévoit notamment d'accroître les
pouvoirs de la police
face aux manifestations non violentes
des fourgons de police brûlé plusieurs
polices secondes
[Applaudissements]
la ministre de l'intérieur priti patel
dénonce des selles inacceptable le maire
de bristol souhaite lui une réponse qui
doit être collective
il s'agit d'un comportement totalement
inacceptable qui va à l'encontre de tout
ce que nous avons fait dans cette ville
ces dernières années pour construire des
partenariats construire une action
collective et faire en sorte que ce soit
une build équité dans laquelle les gens
sont pris en charge sur les pancartes
des manifestants des messages forts dit
non à un état policier ou encore la
liberté de manifester fondamental pour
la démocratie
les rassemblements de masse ont pourtant
actuellement interdit en angleterre en
raison de la pandémie de coronavirus à
londres ce samedi une manifestation
antiraciste et contre le confinement a
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
personnes
ils doivent accepter de laisser les gens
faire preuve de solidarité c'est notre
choix au final et c'est ce qu'ils font
il nous enlève nos libertés il semble y
avoir une grande tentative de la part du
gouvernement de restreindre notre droit
d'être dans la rue et de sortir ou
d'abord une roue jamais à notre droit
est de protester
au moins 36 personnes ont été arrêtées
et plusieurs policiers blessés
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis liverpool avec francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen
l'université de huntsville
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizzuto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
ministre de l'intérieur qui donc a
dénoncé des scènes inacceptable à
bristol la violence et le désordre
commis par une minorité ne seront jamais
toléré dit elle tout d'abord qu'on en
sache un peu plus sur cette minorité
quelle est cette minorité selon vous qui
manifestent en angleterre un bon soir ne
fait aucun doute
nous parlons effectivement d'une
minorité de personnes quelques centaines
de personnes sur plusieurs milliers de
manifestants
ok j'ai travaillé sans l'occurrence de
condamner ces scènes de violence du vent
bas mais il faut se rappeler que cela
peut peut-être choquant à voir
or minimes et nous avons vu la même
chose en europe en allemagne en thuringe
en france où il va a donc exagéré le
niveau de violence une véritable
problème une véritable sujet selon moi
c'est un sujet très grave c'est
l'étendue de la restriction du
gouvernement avec une loi un très
général qui semble à restreindre le
droit des citoyens à manifester
pacifiquement
de toute évidence oui important de
garder à l'esprit qu'il nous sommes en
plein qui s'agitait sa distanciation
sociale et les règles similaires
devraient être respectés cependant cette
loi ne concerne pas les manifestations
de vie de toutes les manifestations
pacifiques qui sont concernés si l'on
commence
c'est à dire si votre manifestation est
trop brillante
alors on a le pouvoir de l'interrompre
un sujet de préoccupation le
gouvernement va peut-être trop loin le
meurtre de sarah evrard c'est ce qui a
créé la grande colère au royaume uni on
le rappelle ans cette jeune femme qui a
été agressé et tué par un policier
c'est cela qui a accentué ce sentiment
antipolis et il n'y aurait pas dû avoir
d'interdiction à manifester ça a mis de
l'huile sur le feu selon vous ben moi
cet incident ce fait est vraiment
tragique est terrible il a effectivement
été tué par un policier sur thomas ce
qui n'est pas le sujet c'est un
meurtrier une personne de fins terrible
qui a décidé de tuer une femme sans
défense
mais la question pour la police de fonds
pour permettre les manifestations
pacifiques
suite à l'assassinât de quelqu'un puis
représente la violence envers les femmes
de ce fut pour moi c'était un choix très
difficile pour les pilotes mais au vu de
la frustration de la colère il aurait dû
laisser la manifestation c'est
poursuivre et leurs interventions
aggraver une situation parfois la loi et
ceux qui la font tu habitais ceux qui
font appliquer la loi duff doivent
adopter une approche délicate
cette manifestation à londres heures et
la gestion par la police je ne pense pas
causé ces violences à bristol il ne faut
pas
jaccar de mélanger je pense qu'il y à un
niveau de frustration s'est levé dans
toutes les strates de la société du
havre ou à cause de ce très long
confinement et les gens sont
effectivement un frustré par le manque
de liberté que le gouvernement attaque
leur droit de manifester pacifiquement
cela mène à des explosions comme on l'a
vu à bristol vous l'avez dit francesco
raid auto c'est un thème qu'on retrouve
finalement ailleurs en europe en france
notamment on est bien placé pour le
savoir en espagne est-ce que selon vous
le droit fondamental de manifester est
il en danger dans royaume uni mais aussi
donc dans les autres démocraties
occidentales
il faut trouver un équilibre entre le
droit de manifester pacifiquement et le
contexte actuel et la santé we need a
sécurité du public
il faut pas comprendre l'objectif
l'objet de la manifestation du 2 août
je redoutais souvent démunis et ailleurs
en europe
peut-être au royaume uni car c'est là
que le jeu arrive dans une situation et
puis surprise on dit on la police
interrompre une manifestation parce
qu'elle est trop brillante parce qu elle
parce que les perturbatrices les
manifestations sont brillantes les
manifestations au but
d'autres perturbatrice afin d'éveiller
les consciences de sensibiliser et avoir
des manifestations bruyantes dans une
démocratie ce n'est pas bon signe cela
montre que le système démocratique et au
mende
personnes qui souhaitent à plaire à
d'autres qui pensent que le droit de
manifester
le droit de ne pas être d'accord doit
être contrôlée voir limitée cela
m'inquiète
merci francesco risotto professeur de
droit européen l'université de redjil
d'avoir été avec nous en direct pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir retour en france
et un procès de quatre jours surtout
symbolique celui à du saccage de l'arc
de triomphe par les gilet jaune dix
personnes sont jugés à partir
d'aujourd'hui pour avoir dégradé le
monument parisien au cours d'une
manifestation fin 2010 8 400 personnes
avaient été interpellées au moment des
faits mais des principaux responsables
n'ont jamais été retrouvés on fait le
point avec notre reporter luc hallé géo
tribunal de grande instance de paris
il y avait que sept personnes
aujourd'hui présente devant le tribunal
correctionnel à paris sept hommes
originaires principalement de province
la présidente a commencé par montrer des
images de graffitis mise sur les piliers
de l'arc de triomphe ce jour là c'était
le 1er décembre 2018 la journée la plus
violente du mouvement des gilet jaune
lors de l'acte iii
il y avait eu d'importantes dégradations
à l'arc de triomphe pour un million
d'euros en tout une véritable
profanation pour l'avocat d'une
association en partie civile de défense
du patrimoine
je vous propose de l'écouter a lyon
c'est évidemment un monument d'abord
patrimoniale historique
c'est également un musée qui a été
saccagé mais c'est un lieu de mémoire
national d'unité nationale qui et je
dirai à traverser tous les régimes
initié par napoléon dur est sauvé par la
restauration
et réutilisées par la république puisque
le soldat inconnu commencer tous de 1920
repose dans cette cette enceinte qui est
un lieu sacré patriotique tous les
français se retrouvent présent aussi à
ce procès pour apporter leur soutien aux
prévenus
des militants d gilet jaune pour la
plupart je vous propose d'écouter faouzi
lellouche militants gilet jaune que j'ai
pu interviewer au début de ce procès
c'est facile de mettre ça sur le dos de
la profanation parce qu'à un moment
donné faut vous dire aussi qu'il y avait
un mutisme et un dénigrement complet du
gouvernement et donc on peut pas pousser
les gens à bout
et puis après c'est s'étonner que les
gens ne sont pas contents
donc c'est vrai qu'on était on était
énormément de monde ce jour-là quand on
était dans les débuts dans les premiers
actes mais il faut voir aussi qu'on nous
a amenés là moi je me souviens on a
voulu se présenter sur les champs
elysées c'est un peu compliqué d'y
rentrer fallait présenter ses papiers
et puis comme un seul homme on a conduit
tout le monde vers l'arc de triomphe et
on nous a enfermés là bas dans une nasse
géante
il nous a fallu presque moi il m'a fallu
trois heures pour en sortir mais je peux
vous dire sur les sous le coude et des
ailes bd des gaz lacrymogènes et voilà
donc ça aurait pu être n'importe qui
donc à un moment donné faut pas
s'étonner qu'il ya des dommages
collatéraux 400 personnes avaient été
arrêtées ce jour-là mais la justice
avait eu du mal à définir des
responsabilités ferme sur des actes de
dégradations majeures
sept autres personnes vont être jugées
pour de simples intrusion normalement
devant des tribunaux de police quoi
qu'il en soit ici le résultat de ce
procès il est attendu vendredi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
sophie tissier et coordinatrice de
l'association force jaune ou bonsoir
tissier merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france et images évidemment tout
le monde s'en souvient l'ont choqué
créer de l'émoi dans l'opinion dans quel
état d'esprit s'ouvre ce procès c'est un
procès pour moi qui est celui d'abord
qui n'est pas celui de vrais gilet jaune
je voudrais dire que les personnes qui
ont commis ces actes absolument
révoltant de voir voilà des objets du
patrimoine être attaqué à l'époque les
vrais coupables n'ont jamais été arrêtés
et je pense même qu'ils sont protégés il
ya eu à l'époque beaucoup de témoignages
de personnes disant que des hommes en
noir ayant revêtu un gilet jaune ont été
laissées en les a laissé s'introduire
sur place et je trouve très étrange
qu'on n'ait jamais arrêter les vrais
coupables
alors aujourd'hui où il ya des traces
adn ou il ya des caméras de surveillance
où il y avait quand même des moyens de
retrouver ces personnes je pense que
réellement j'apporte mon soutien à ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui dans ce procès
parce que pour moi ce sont des boucs
émissaires et les vrais gilet jaune sont
des gens qui étaient pacifiques qui
effectivement se sont retrouvés dans
cette nasse géante orchestrée par le
pouvoir et où des gens ultra radicaliser
qui ne sont pas des gilet jaune mais qui
ont enfilé un gilet jaune opportunément
sont venues pour saccager pour emmener
la masse vers la violence et pour
discréditer totalement le mouvement
donc je suis assez accablé de voir
partout dans la presse
c'est cet amalgame fait systématiquement
alors qu'on le sait aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs en janvier 2019
quatre personnes avaient déjà été
arrêtées et condamnées et c'était des
personnes issus des mouvances ultra
droite du gud notamment une mouvance qui
revendique d'appeler à tuer le bourgeois
est également on a vu autour de l'arc de
triomphe d'aider les dégradations
montrait que c'était des groupes
également de l'ultra gauche
donc c'est cette alliance d'une toute
petite minorité qui a été largement
laissé
faire à l'époque par les forces de
l'ordre et par le pouvoir qui ont
encouragé ça pour permettre de
discréditer tout un mouvement et je
trouve ça encore vraiment désolant
qu'aujourd'hui médiatiquement tout le
monde parle du procès deux gilet jaune
qui ont saccagé l'arc de triomphe
c'est ça la ccit si je résume voir des
cévennes énorme manipulation au oui
c'est ce que j'allais dire sophie
tissier si je résume votre propos il ya
une forme de manipulation les dix
personnes qui sont sur le banc des est
prévenu aujourd'hui ne sont pas les
réels coupable il y aurait eu une forme
de laisser faire c'est ça qu'on comprend
bien sûr c'est un lynchage
on est en train de le lyncher des
coupables idéals des compas vidéo pardon
pour simplement montrer l'exemple et
pour discréditer encore une fois les
gilets jaunes et pour dire regardez
c'était des personnes violentes
s'étaient des personnes on voit sur les
images ce qui jette principalement des
projectiles sont des personnes tout en
noir d'ailleurs et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le black block c'est une
alliance ultra à la fois extrême droite
extrême gauche et qui est je tiens à le
dénoncer
soutenu par les réseaux sociaux facebook
twitter
moi mon compte personnel moi qui suis
pacifique est censuré je tiens
aujourd'hui en direct a dénoncé le
pouvoir qui volontairement censure les
personnes pacifiques qui cherche à
organiser les luttes les réelles
opposant militants pacifiques gilet
jaune sont censurés et toutes les
mouvances ultra et violentes sont
boostées par les réseaux sociaux avec la
complicité de l'état de la police des rg
j'en sais rien dans tous les cas du
pouvoir il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
moi je suis fichée s alors que je suis
pacifique que je n'ai commis aucune
dégradation jamais j'ai toujours été
légaliste j'ai toujours prôné
d'organiser les manifestations
correctement pour justement éviter
empêcher l'infiltration de groupuscules
ultra et d'autres se voient ils sont
piégés les mauvaises âmes des
accusations on les remet pas en cause
ici et votre compte a été fermé à quelle
occasion
précisément voilà aujourd'hui par
exemple on m'a censuré c'est à dire que
je suis shadowbane et je subis du shadow
banking
c'est un moyen qu'ont mis en place les
réseaux sociaux vous pouvez chercher sur
internet c'est on cache les postes des
personnes qui sont shadowbane et mon
compte semble actif mais les personnes
ne reçoivent jamais de notification les
toutes les personnes qui suivent et les
algorithmes limite complètement la
portée de toutes les publications que je
fais moi mais qui est également les
personnes de mon groupe et les personnes
des de nos réseaux sociaux avec force
jaune dont ils ferment en bénéficier
vous utilisation de la violence elle est
réelle en tout cas c'est votre opinion
vous exprimer sur rt france ce soir
clairement ça a porté un coup dur au
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune ce genre
d'imagés d'ailleurs les d'autres scènes
de violence qui rend qui ont évidemment
là la violence la violence de ces images
est terrible et on déplore il faut d
inacceptable qu'il ait des gens qui est
profané l'arc de triomphe qui est cassé
qui ait commis des dégradations ne peut
pas laisser passer on ne peut jamais
justifier la violence
il faut savoir que ces groupuscules là
ils sont très minoritaires
le guide ou les groupes ultras extrême
gauche de black blocks ce sont quelques
centaines de personnes
et d'ailleurs ils sont parfois renforcée
par des militants ultra venus
d'allemagne de belgique ou d'italie ou
d'autres pays parce que c'est une
mouvance radicaliser qui est d'ailleurs
on peut dire promotionner quelque part
par aussi les médias et il y à toute
cette mouvance et cette fausse
stratégique régulièrement diffusés dans
les mouvements sociaux de dire il faut
faire les choses clandestinement il faut
être tous masqués aujourd'hui c'est avec
la crise covin à l'époque du mouvement
black blocks
il faut toujours être dans la dent dans
l'illégalité
il faut s'opposer à l'état de façon
ferme il faut être radicaux sinon on est
des vendus on est des collabos moi vous
savez je lutte depuis des années et de
fait d'être pacifiques et de revendiquer
le pacifisme j'ai reçu énormément
d'attaqués y compris de du camp
politique d'extrême gauche y compris par
exemple de la banda ruches en jeu le
site
voilà
monsieur rufin qui par exemple défendez
les groupes de black blocks à
l'assemblée nationale et cerveau non
disponibles peuple révolté il dénonçait
que soi-disant ces groupes étaient
censurés ce qui est faux ils sont en
réalité boosté par les réseaux sociaux
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir le nombre
de followers de cépages et la réalité
c'est qu'il ya une totale
instrumentalisation des groupuscules
violents qui vont infiltrer les
mouvements sociaux pour les pour les
radicaliser afin de discréditer et afin
de faire monter toujours cette violence
parce que le pouvoir en fait se sert de
nos émotions
il se sert de la peur aujourd'hui avec
le co vite pour nous contrôler il se
sert également de nos colères et la
colère des gens elle est
instrumentalisée ci et pour la mener
vers une haine une haine contre la
police une haine évidemment des
bourgeois de l'oligarchie etc et faire
monter les tensions pour que les
mouvements s'autodétruisent parce que
plus les manifestants vont être dans une
radicalité plus ça renforce en réalité
l'état puisque ça justifie la montée de
la répression ça justifie des lois
violente et aux yeux de la population
qui regardent comme aujourd'hui ces
images de violence ils se disent oh là
là mais c'est scandaleux il faut les
contenir il faut des lois répressives il
faut une police plus forte pour les
empêcher etc
mais c'est vraiment une totale
manipulation de a à z et j'en suis
témoin parce que je la vis et je vous
dis moi qui suis pacifique je suis
censuré je suis empêché d'agir
personne ne relaient la parole de notre
goût et je suis fichée s et je aimé mes
comptes sont censurés et shadowbane est
aujourd'hui clairement c'est ma dernière
peut ni question sophie tissier
justement sur ces médias sociaux
aujourd'hui vous avez demandé des
comptes que vous avez eu des réponses
après ce que vous estimez jamais
vraiment pris une censure c'est ça c'est
là c'est ça qui est terrible
je n'arrête pas de contester les
décisions de facebook de twitter et on
n'a aucun moyen de recours
je ne fais je n'arrête pas d'envoyer des
mails de co2 de protestation en disant
c'est pas normal vous me couper mes
comptes pourquoi mais mes publications
de sont plus visibles je vois bien les
progressions des publications elle
n'avance jamais sont jamais diffusé
parfois j'ai des
des procédés auxquels je n'arrive pas
j'arrive par partager j'arrive pas a
commenté j'arrive tout un tas de choses
qui me sont enlevés et c'est la réalité
et on n'a aucun retour aucun moyen de
recours puisque twitter et facebook
étend aux états unis il faudrait les
attaques et aux états unis avec des
moyens énormes au niveau juridique que
je n'ai pas et pour l'instant je n'ai
aucun autre moyen que de dénoncer
publiquement et que de les accuser
jacchus facebook j'accuse twitter de
fomenter la violence et de est de faire
en sorte que ça serve le pouvoir pour
discréditer les gens qui comme en essais
de de militer pacifiquement et je dis
aux jeunes il faut absolument que vous
ne tombiez pas dans le piège de la
violence qui est vraiment le meilleur
moyen de renforcer l'état vous êtes
persuadé d'être dans une opposition vrai
et dans une désobéissance
alors que c'est le pire moyen pour
renforcer en réalité le pouvoir de la
police que d'être que d'être dans une
confrontation et de revendiquer cette
confrontation et c'est ce qui a
malheureusement détruit les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui quel est votre moyen de vous
vous exprimez si vous n'avez pu les les
réseaux sociaux on a très peu de moyens
merci de nous donner la parole samedi
dernier nous avons organisé une
manifestation avec force jaune et avec
beaucoup d'autres groupes d'ailleurs
collectif contre la dictature sanitaire
c'était place de la fontaine des
innocents à châtelet-les-halles on était
quelques centaines de personnes
aucun relais média personne n'a parlé de
cette manifestation on en organise une
de nouveau samedi prochain d'ailleurs
j'invite toutes les personnes qui sont
révoltés contre la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et qui dénonce aussi la
dictature sanitaires à venir samedi à la
manifestation à 14h à
châtelet-les-halles c'est une
manifestation déclarée autorisé où il
n'y a aucune violence policière
parce que la police fait très bien le
distinguo les policiers du terrain
savent très bien que notre groupe n'est
pas du tout dans un objectif de violence
et de et de casse et d'agressivité donc
on a tout à fait l'autorisation est
d'ailleurs nous avions été avec force
jeune j'avais été moi même plaidé le 7
novembre dernier au tribunal
administratif pour protéger le droit de
manifester puisque le préfet de police
sous prétexte des mages
sanitaires à faire respecter interdisait
les manifestations et empêcher les
déclarants comme notre groupe de pouvoir
manifester à l'époque au parvis des
droits de l'homme et je suis allé au
tribunal administratif de paris plaider
la cause de la liberté de manifester et
défendre par le droit notre liberté et
nous avions gagné on avait levé fait
lever trois arrêtés préfectoraux
d'ailleurs rt vous nous aviez vous aviez
informer les téléspectateurs de de cette
action juridique et grâce à cette action
aujourd'hui on continue d'avoir le droit
de manifester en france donc on le fait
samedi et les suivants on va être tous
les samedis place de la fontaine des
innocents avec un maximum de collectif
il ya des réseaux comme le réseau rsa
les collectifs de parents contre le
masque pour les enfants mais également
réaction 19 enfants ces libertés plein
de collectif
ami entends-tu qui sont des artistes qui
demande l'ouverture des théâtres
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on défende notre
liberté de manifester parce que c'est
fondamental si on veut défendre nos
droits et nos libertés il faut pouvoir
manifester et manifester pacifiquement
pour pas avoir évidemment ni la police à
doni la gendarmerie à dos et pour pas
dégrader l'image des mouvements pour
pâques à la télévision on focalise tous
sur les violences
les violences policières la montre
l'escaladé de la violence et des
tensions qui à la fois font peur à tous
ceux qui regardent les gens n'ont plus
envie de venir
comme on a peur quand on voit de ces
images terrifiantes de voitures brûlées
de violence les gens se disent mais
surtout faut pas leur manifestation et
ils craignent d'être réprimée donc nous
on a réussi avec notre groupe à mettre
en place ce processus de déclaration
manif collective on revendique le
pacifisme et ça fonctionne et on est en
train de monter une grande coordination
stop à la dictature sanitaires stop aux
masques pour les enfants parce que c'est
odieux ce qu'ont fait subir à nos
anciens dernière question juge notamment
toutes les mesures
vous y croyez à cette suite c'est ma
dernière question est très rapidement si
vous pouvez vous y croyez à cette suite
du mouvement
justement d'aider gilet jaune
aujourd'hui après la crise peut-être du
coc vide écoutez les gilet jaune ça a
été un mouvement tellement historiques
mondial ça a été vu
ça a été repris dans le monde entier
bien sûr qu'il ya eu cette perte de
vitesse je pense que
l'instrumentalisation du coc vidé pour
énormément dans la menuiserie du
mouvement mais croyez moi il ya encore
beaucoup de gens en gilet jaune qui sont
qui soutiennent les jets les jeunes dans
leur coeur et qui ont compris aussi les
manipulations qu'il y a eu pour empêcher
ce mouvement de s'organiser de grandir
de progresser dans la bonne direction et
nous en tous les cas moi c'est à ça que
j'offre de tout mon coeur j'ai vraiment
envie que tous les gens qui ont soutenu
le mouvement à un moment tous les gens
qui ont sorti le gilet jaune reviennent
suis fort ce jeu nous montrent des
groupes fort ce jaune partout en france
parce que nous avons une charte
nous avons une charte de valeurs et qui
est fidèle à l'origine du mouvement a
partisans sans syndicats un mouvement
citoyen avec que des gens qui
revendiquent leurs droits leur liberté
leurs droits fondamentaux de pouvoir
vivre dignement de la justice sociale
après tout les évidemment toutes les
revendications mais aujourd'hui surtout
de défendre la liberté nos libertés
fondamentales qui sont en train d'être
détruite par l'instrumentaliser la crise
la sous-utilisation de la crise merci
beau merci de m'avoir donné la parole
aux liqueurs et merci bien voyager mais
merci pour votre témoignage sophie
tissier coordinatrice de l'association
force jaune dans quelques instants
rester avec nous nous parlerons des 21
millions de français qui expérimente
depuis samedi un confinement nouvelle
version alors que la lassitude gagne de
plus en plus la population un peu plus
d'un an après la première mise sous
cloche et puis nous parlerons de la
stratégie vaccinale européenne mieux
refuse de céder au nationalisme
vaccinale mais suite de nombreuses
critiques en raison des retards de
livraison
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï kg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l oblique
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fans ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et dans l'hymne quel
rôle pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et
big for books les gaffes à s'organiser
pour annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux hanul à des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême cerexhe est un terreau qui peut
favoriser l'extension du terrorisme ne
faut pas imaginer qu'il suffit
simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre pour
que l'islam c'est un mac sont embrigadés
ils ont été séduits ils ont été
manipulés et d'autres qui agissent de
manière parfaitement consciente et
lucide je respecterai toujours
l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
le pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 22 mars freiner sans enfermer
20 terminaux france expérimentent depuis
samedi le confinement en mode hybride de
nouvelles mesures mises en place pour
faire face à la troisième vague alors
que la lassitude de la population est de
plus en plus manifeste jean castex
réunissait aujourd'hui plusieurs
ministres à matignon sur le thème de la
santé mentale des français pour préparer
un plan d'action
la troisième vague et des campagnes
vaccinales qui patine l'armée et les
pompiers vont déployer au moins 35
grands centres pour pouvoir être capable
d'utiliser toutes les doses qui seront
livrés à la france à partir du mois
d'avril
l'europe elle accuse toujours des
retards de livraison mais on exporte des
millions dans le monde entier
un sommet est prévu en fin de semaine en
visioconférence à outre-atlantique à
présent mais ni de twitter depuis
janvier donald trump à faire son retour
sur les réseaux sociaux d'ici deux à
trois mois avec sa propre plateforme
selon la déclaration d'un conseiller de
l'ancien président américain qui
comptait pas moins de 88 millions
d'abonnés
l'élection présidentielle au congo
brazzaville marquée par la mort de guy
brice parfait kolélas ce décès des ducs
au vide lors de son transfert médicalisé
vers la france le soixantenaire était
considéré comme le principal rival au
président sortant denis sassou nguesso
au pouvoir depuis maintenant trente six
ans
il vise une réélection dès le premier
tour les résultats du scrutin d'hier ne
sont pas attendus avant plusieurs jours
[Musique]
le
depuis ce week-end 16 départements font
donc face à de nouvelles restrictions
pour lutter contre le coc vide
un tiers des français soumis donc un
confinement allégé qui devrait durer
minimum quatre semaines
la situation à l'hôpital elle demeure
tendue nouvelle réunion ce matin autour
du gouvernement ont fait le point avec
estelle farges ne parlait pas de
confinement mais plutôt de nouvelles
mesures de freinage supplémentaires ce
terme un peu technocratique il est signé
emmanuel macron déclarations faites à
des journalistes en marge d'une
rencontre à l'elysée lors de la journée
à de la francophonie déclaration qui
vient aussi contredire les propos tenus
par jean castex lors de sa dernière
conférence de presse jeudi dernier
alors si ce premier week-end de
printemps a été marqué donc par de
nouvelles restrictions il a aussi été à
part quelques couacs de la part du
gouvernement tout d'abord sur
l'attestation qui devait faire son grand
retour le gouvernement a finalement
renoncé face aux critiques et aux
moqueries ch pas moins de 15 motifs de
sorties et des règles jugé illisible
alors l'opposition évidemment s'en est
donné à coeur joie qualifiant cette
attestation de chefs-d'oeuvre
bureaucratique chez les républicains par
exemple ou de symboles de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
du côté de la france
insoumise dorénavant les français vivant
dans les départements concernés par ces
mesures peuvent sortir avec seulement un
justificatif de domicile avant le
couvre-feu instauré à 19h et dans la
limite d'un périmètre de 10 km autour de
leur domicile et situation confuse aussi
autour à des invitations à domicile le
porte parole du gouvernement a été sans
ambiguïté vous ne pouvez pas inviter
chez vous des personnes pour un dîner
elle ni pour un déjeuner at il est
déclaré des propos qui ont poussé le
ministère de l'intérieur
à une petite précision auprès de nos
confrères de bfm tv
il s'agissait d'une recommandation et
non d'une interdiction les
verbalisations ne sont possibles qu'en
cas de fêtes clandestines où deux êtres
tapage nocturne alors concrètement
comment les français ont-ils perçu ce
nouveau tour de vis et tour de vis voyez
ces témoignages au micro de nicolas
coupé je n'ai aucun jugement trop
stricte ou pas assez strictes
factuellement ça nous rajoute à ça nous
donne juste une heure de plus
mais ça change rien à notre quotidien en
fait ni avant ni après
la preuve c'est que on s'est tous
regardés en maths bon bah du coup n'a
gagné leurs deux courses sincèrement
c'est pas un confinement puisqu'on est
dehors et qui a pas de problème
simplement je pense que il y avait
vraiment une compréhension psychologique
de l'état d'esprit de la plupart des
français je pense qu'un peu une
dictature sanitaire quoi c'est tout tout
tout au nom des deux fois la barre du
cosy devons surtout s'occuper d'eux des
jeunes gens trop s'occuper des
commerçants ce qui fait d'eux voilà quoi
femmes d'orange un peu parce que pour
moi c'est pas un continent parce que il
ya tout le monde dans la rue non ça
changerai mon quotidien n'y a pas grand
chose qui change c'est même encore mieux
le soir pour sortir jusqu'à 19 heures
donc non pas de changement outre ces
seize départements de nouveaux
territoires pourraient être concernés
par ces restrictions dans les 15 jours
ou trois semaines à venir déclarations
dans les colonnes du quotidien nice
matin d' olivier guérin médecins et
nouveau membre du conseil scientifique
et nous sommes avec thierry mariani
député européen du rassemblement
national bonsoir tia lima
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france me libre me confiner ou confinés
à l'extérieur on ne sait pas trop si les
français d'ailleurs ne savent pas bien
ce que c'est il est évident qu'ils en
ont assez
la lassitude le pire ennemi du
gouvernement on avait dans votre région
d'ailleurs un paca notamment à marseille
la lassitude et puis la compréhension
devant toute une série de mesures qui
sont qui partent dans tous les sens le
meilleur exemple c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec les attestations ou vous avez
vu d'abord on a eu une première
attestation puis une deuxième
attestation puis les français savent
plus quoi remplir
là je suis à bruxelles j'ai vu à la gare
les français savent plus quel papier
montrer excusez moi cette boutade mais
la bureaucratie soviétique a disparu il
ya 30 ans mais ma compétence elle de la
reconstituer en france à l'occasion de
cette crise et puis tout ça n'a aucun
sens je veux dire désormais c'est quoi
c'est une attestation pour que les
français s'autorise même à sortir en
sachant très bien que en réalité les
adresses qui sont données souvent ce
sont des adresses symbolique donc les
français ont l'impression que les
emmerdes qu'on leur fait pas confiance
et je pense que c'est ça qui les agace
de plus en plus c'est à dire qu'à côté
d'une minorité extrême minorité qui ne
respectent pas les mesures de sécurité
on l'a vu effectivement hier à marseille
à ce carnaval qui est également
organisée par des organisations en
rappelant le d'extrême gauche là
l'écrasante majorité des français sont
sérieux mais c'est le pendant qu'on les
prenne au sérieux qu'on ne les prenne
plus pour des enfants et qu'on arrête de
leur faire remplir des pieds des bills
sérieux mais quand même un peu déprimé
d'ailleurs il y avait une réunion autour
de cela apparemment emmanuel macron nous
dit on est très préoccupée par le le
moral des français
doit-on craindre selon vous un effet
cocotte minute
on voit des gens qui à quelques
manifestations ici ou là notamment en
allemagne
bah écoutez c'est vrai que pour certains
français ça devient totalement
insupportable
je pense aux jeunes en particulier vous
savez j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
d'étudiants pendant le week-end quand
vous êtes étudiant à paris par exemple
que vous payez pouvez vous payer à fait
une chambre de 12 mètres carrés que vous
êtes quasiment confinés à l'intérieur
sans pouvoir sortir à part dans la
journée ou le soir vous devez rester
sans voir personne
et puis je pense aussi excusez-moi
commerçants parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
quand même 90 mille commerçants dans ses
seize départements qui sont fermées avec
des aberrations les coiffeurs sont
ouverts mais pas les esthéticiennes
franchement les esthéticiennes sont
aussi responsables que les coiffeurs
elles sont capables d'appliquer des
gestes de protocoles et vous avez des
séries de profession par exemple vous
prendre les chaussures alors aujourd'hui
pouvaient plus acheter vos chaussures
dans un magasin mais vous pouvez les
acheter sur amazon et puis alors si vous
êtes dans ma région
si vous allez sur ce qu'on appelle les
marchés de provence en plein air vous
pouvez les acheter sur les marchés va
tout ça manque de logique manque de
cohérence et et c'est vrai que tout cela
finit par saouler les français mais
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire thierry
mariani est confiné de manière stricte
fermé absolument tout comme en mars
dernier qu'elle était là la boue moins
pire des solutions si j'ose dire
l'attendait depuis le début c'est à dire
depuis le début de la crise marine le
pen a dit très clairement deux choses 1
fermeture des frontières et de
déconfinement région fermeture des
frontières monsieur macron a refusé
souvenez-vous au début ils disent hey
man 2 selon dieu sait les nationalistes
qui demande ça c'est horrible
là on voit aujourd'hui par exemple toute
une série de pays européens ont pris des
mesures identiques
l'allemagne est finalement on a bien vu
il ya quelques mois que lui-même a dû
reconnaître qu'il fallait fermer les
frontières entre temps que de temps
perdu mais ces deuxièmes ballons trop
tard donc aujourd'hui c'est trop tard
parce qu'effectivement monsieur macro
n'a pas voulu prendre les mesures
appropriées
ensuite sur le confinement par région où
il ça c'est la bonne solution mais il
faut aussi dans ce cas là que ce soit
j'allais dire gagnant gagnant pour ceux
qui qui sont beaucoup moins de toucher
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
je prends un exemple par exemple la
région parisienne est extrêmement
touchée effectivement elle est confinée
mais par exemple la bretagne ou
l'occitanie sont beaucoup moins deux
touchés eh bien pourquoi pas dire dans
ces régions là on commence à réouvrir
par exemple les terrasses puisqu'on nous
explique qu'en plein air c'est beaucoup
moins
je re voyez je veux dire il faut donner
de l'espoir aux gens il faut que dans
les régions où le virus circule beaucoup
moins eh bien on puisse libérer des
soupapes pour les commerçants je pense
bien sûr au café parce que vous
connaissez la mentalité française les
terrasses en france c'est ça fait
presque partie du patrimoine et du moral
des français
voilà pourquoi par exemple n'autorise
pas dans ces régions où le co vide à une
circulation beaucoup plus réduite
certains cafés à réouvrir certains
restaurants à réouvrir pourquoi par
exemple alors que le gouvernement m a
enfin reconnu qu'en se confient les
moins à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
après avoir traqué les français qui
étaient sur les plages dans les forêts
dans les montagnes
aujourd'hui on dit pas pour les derniers
jours qui restent aux stations de ski
vous pouvez réouvrir voilà et en a
l'impression qu'en réalité il ya une
stratégie uniquement punitive il ya des
endroits où la circulation est meilleur
et puis il faut que cette situation soit
reconnue et qui à l'assouplissement et
puis enfin vous cette nuit connaissent
très bien et enfin si vous le permettez
en sortira de cette situation quand on
le sait très bien une majorité des
français à condition qu'ils soient
volontaires soient vaccinés or quand
jacques quand j'entends le gouvernement
france et et quand je vois la stratégie
européenne
j'ai entendu le commissaire bretons
encore ce matin sur certaines antennes
dire on continue à on a assez de vaccins
on le rend assez on n'a pas besoin de
faire appel à d'autres vaccins c'est la
vie complètement suicidaire jamais je
fais je vends jolie mariée ni les grands
esprits par contre je vous couper pour
ça thierry breton alors c'était pas les
autres à force était manifestement le
vexin spoutnik virus qui lui posait des
des petits problèmes existentiels aller
les russes qui paraît-il ont du mal à
produire leurs vaccins alors que c'est
vrai que voilà on aime ou on aime pas la
russie peu importe c'est lé premier à
produire ce vaccin est qu'il faudrait
peut-être aidé comment vous expliquez
cette forme en quoi de d'arrogance de
provocation dans la communication de
l'idéologie je vais être extrêmement dur
mais c'est la réalité
au niveau européen on fait passer les a
priori idéologiques avant la santé des
européens
je veux dire aujourd'hui il y aura
peut-être si les acomptes la campagne de
vaccination continue
à fonctionner des européens vont mourir
parce que tout simplement l'europe fait
passer ses a priori c'est a priori
politique avant la santé des français
franchement les vaccins moi je me moque
de savoir s'ils sont russes cubain
chinois nord-coréen
le problème c'est de savoir s'ils sont
efficaces or aujourd'hui tout prouve que
le vaccin russe comme d'autres vaccins
ont prouvé leur efficacité
voilà pourquoi on refuse et en plus
pourquoi en france parce que là aussi on
a un a priori idéologiques de monsieur
macron qui consiste à dire l'europe
l'europe l'europe mais les italiens ont
négocié avec les russes et sont prêts à
produire ce vaccin en italie madame
merkel vous le savez envoyer une mission
en allemagne pour discuter avec les
autorités russes pour produire le vaccin
en russie à la main elle pas de pardon
pour produire ce vaccin en allemagne et
elle a même ajouté
si l'union européenne refuse
d'homologuer ce vaccin est bien les
autorités allemandes le ferons homologué
voilà et pourquoi en france on continue
à être bloquée sur l'europe l'europe
l'europe l'europe a montré son
inefficacité
voilà je pense que cette mine sereine en
train de se diviser sur ce vaccin russe
justement écouter l'europe est surtout
en train de d'avoir deux sortes de pays
ceux qui pensent d'abord à la santé de
leurs concitoyens les italia les
hongrois et d'autres qui disent et les
allemands qui disent voilà aujourd'hui
on manque de vaccins il faut en trouver
partout
eh bien oui à la commande de européenne
mais oui il faut la compléter par
exemple avec les vaccins russe thierry
mariani quand on voit que sur le tarmac
des aéroports allemands on voit des
avions décoller avec un intérieur des
vaccins biotech puisqu'ils ont inventé
produit avec pfizer qu'on les envoie à
dubaï et que des jeunes de 25 ans se
font vacciner
on ce n'est pas un petit peu que
l'europe s'est fait avoir dans cette
affaire l'europe a été nul je crois
qu'il faut dire la vérité
l'europe a montré que c'était d'abord
est à commander les vaccins beaucoup
trop tard parce que la bureaucratie
bruxelloise est hallucinante
voilà l'europe a voulu négocier jusqu'au
bout alors que des pays ont compris que
il valait mieux dépenser quelques
millions de plus pour les vaccins tout
de suite parce qu'en réalité c'était des
économies par cependant bloquée par le
la vie est de lier poids pour dépenser
quelques millions de plus dans les
vaccins
c'était quelques milliards de moins
dépenser pour les subventions et et en
plus je le répète maintenant quand
j'entends le commissaire breton tu pour
te rendre intelligent il nous explique
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'autres vaccins
moi je vois en provence côte d'azur des
médecins des mères qui me disent on est
prêts à vacciner mais on a pas de vaccin
voilà et donc faire passer c'est a
priori idéologiques et gravissime en
plus pardonnez moi mais c'est des a
priori idéologiques véritablement
uniquement dirigé contre la russie
parce que quand on nous explique
pourquoi cause de monsieur navalni en
prison on ne peut pas commander des
vaccins
sacha une personne que monsieur cachot
guillet a été découpé en rondelles par
l'arabie saoudite
quand on achète son pétrole ça ne gêne
pas la politique du qatar quand on
achète son pétrole donc l'union
européenne fait de la morale fait les
droits de l'homme uniquement quand ça
les arrange
elle ferait mieux de s'occuper en
priorité la santé de ses concitoyens
je le répète le les retards que nous
prenons les choix politiques que nous
prenons en choisissant ans et des
vaccins risquent de coûter cher en vies
humaines
thierry mariani berriane air petite
question qui vous concerne indirectement
est d'ailleurs très directement le
gouvernement veut se conformer à l'avis
du conseil scientifique toujours lui
tendu au plus tard le 1er avril pour
décider du maintien ou pas des scrutins
départementales et régionales prévues
les 13 et 20 juin vous êtes d'ailleurs
entre parenthèses donné gagnant face à
renaud muselier si l air lr la
république en marche ne fusionne pas en
région paca votre avis sur ce report
écoutez si on peut se rendre chez son
cordonnier ou chez son coiffeur on peut
passer quelques minutes dans un bureau
de vote
les pays bas par exemple nous en montrer
il ya quelques jours qu'on pouvait tout
à fait faire une élection sans aucun
problème donc soyons sérieux passé deux
minutes dans un bureau de vote où on met
à disposition du gel et on respecte les
gestes barrière permettent de tout à
fait voter d'ailleurs je constate qu'une
dizaine de présidents de conseils
régionaux on dit il faut arrêter de
reporter ces élections
alors après ça va être intéressant parce
que faut pas aussi être naïf je pense
que le rêve secret de monsieur macron
c'est que ces élections soient reportées
soit reporter pourquoi parce que dans ce
cas là ça permettra ça bloquera certains
partis comme les républicaine qui ne
pourront pas désigner leur candidat
assez rapidement et puis ça évitera
aussi au parti de la république en
marche de se prendre probablement une
raclée monumentale parce que les
français ont compris une chose c'est que
pour gérer la crise visiblement macron
sap a été un champion
merci thierry mariani député européen du
rassemblement national d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france
l'europe n'a absolument pas besoin du
spoutnik v on vient d'en parler ce sont
les mots du commissaire européen au
marché intérieur
thierry breton qui misent donc sur des
vaccins disponibles pour atteindre
l'immunité collective en europe d'ici au
14 juillet pas besoin du scouting v que
les russes auraient un mal fou à
fabriquer rajoute le commissaire
européen qui laisse entendre que ce
serait moscou qui aurait besoin de
l'aide de l'europe
étrange déclaration dénonce vladimir
poutine les correspondances à moscou
d'antoine frérot le président du conseil
européen charles michel a estimé que la
russie était responsable du mauvais état
de ses relations avec l'union européenne
tout en appelant moscou à faire des
efforts sur les droits humains et la
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk en
ukraine en réponse vladimir poutine a
regretté de façon générale la position
conflit
ul de l'union européenne envers la
russie et justement s'il ya bien un
domaine en ce moment ont constaté des
crispations c'est bien la vaccination
dimanche soir thierry breton jugeait que
l'union européenne n'avait pas besoin du
vaccin russe et ce malgré la pénurie de
vaccins constatée sur le vieux continent
pl dire poutine a réagi un peu plus tôt
dans la journée en se demandant quelles
étaient les réelles motivations du
commissaire européen
fischer comme on vient de le rapporter à
l'instant un des responsables de la
commission européenne a déclaré nous
n'avons pas besoin de soutenir v skyrim
nicki minaj une déclaration ch et
arrange
nous n'imposons rien à personne et en
europe nombreux sont ceux qui ne savent
pas ce que la russie a déposé il ya le
temps d'affiner la demande
d'enregistrement de son vaccin auprès de
l'alliance européenne des médicaments
cela a été fait comme tatiana golikova a
rapporté ce matin le 21 janvier 2021
tuer ce n'est que le 4 mars que nous
avons été informés du fait que notre
demande commencer à être examinées je
tiens à dire à cet égard comme je viens
de l'indiquer que nous n'imposons rien à
personne mais quand nous entendons des
représentants officiels faire de telles
déclarations
une question s'impose quels intérêts et
représentent de telles personnes
les intérêts de sociétés pharmaceutiques
ou ceux des citoyens des pays européens
qu'est-ce qu'ils font du lobbying il
n'empêche que le spoutnik v est
actuellement en train d'être examinés en
vue de son autorisation de mise sur le
marché européen dans ce cadre l'équipe
d'experts de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments est d'ailleurs attendu en
russie le 10 avril prochain
quoi qu'il en soit vladimir poutine l'a
rappelé la russie ne force personne à
accepter ces vaccins 55 pays dans le
monde font déjà confiance à spoutnik v
et à ce jour aucun effet secondaire
sérieux n'a été constaté à la suite de
son administration
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude blanche
maison merci
être avec nous pour continuer à analyser
notamment les propos de thierry breton
quel jeu joue t-il
ben je crois qu'il joue sa partition sa
partition au niveau européen et sa
partition au niveau français comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure la
responsabilité qu'il a au sein de la
commission c'est le marché intérieur et
pas autre chose
et dans ce cadre là la présidente de la
commission lui a confié une mission
particulière qui est de superviser les
capacités de production de vaccin sur le
territoire de l'union européenne dont
pilar il a dit hier de télévision en
effet qui avait 55 usine de production
de vaccins des vaccins autorisés par l'
agence européenne du médicament sur le
territoire de l'europe et qu' il y avait
eu énormément de retard en effet de
livraison que cela dit des choses
s'amélioraient que les livraisons
doubler chaque mois pratiquement de
telle sorte que fin juin début juillet
nous en serions à 350 millions de doses
livré au total depuis le mois de janvier
et c'est là où il a fait également une
petite allusion typiquement françaises
en dix ans le 14 juillet le 14 juillet
nous aurons atteint l'immunité
collective puisque il y aura
suffisamment de gens ivres ont été
vaccinées en france et dans l'union
européenne pour que nous ayons atteint
ce seuil magique de l'immunité
collective
mais il a ajouté une petite phrase de
prudence un codicille dix ans si
toutefois les délais sont respectés dans
les livraisons futures
or effectivement ils n'ont pas été dans
les livres en passer je vois pas
pourquoi ils le seraient dans les
livraisons futures
alors il a ensuite ajouté que suivant le
schéma qui l'exposait et dans le cadre
de ses responsabilités et considéré il
répondait à une question journalistes
que en effet il ne pensait pas que dans
l'immédiat l'union européenne avait
besoin du vaccin russe et qu'on verrait
au deuxième semestre mais ça sa
démonstration
si les délais est si les livraisons
étaient conformes aux prévisions montre
bien qu'il ya évidemment une place pour
le vaccin russe est de toute façon tout
cela doit être soumis pour décision
au conseil européen qui se tiendra jeudi
et vendredi prochains donc c'était une
sorte de préparation peut être
maladroite au conseil européen de jeudi
et vendredi prochains
et on verra bien à ce qui sera décidé la
chancelière merkel qui a beaucoup de bon
sens a déjà dit ce qu'elle pensait bien
entendu l'allemagne compte recourir le
moment venu au vaccin russe au spoutnik
v et elle entend le faire tant mieux si
l' agence européenne a donné le feu vert
mais sinon et bien l'allemagne utilisera
son agence nationale et je crois que
c'est le bon sens et que en effet il est
possible de le faire aussi dans d'autres
pays par exemple en france car il n'a
jamais été dit que l'union européenne
avait un monopole monopole de
fournitures ou monopole d'homologation
la compétence de la santé elle est dans
les états membres dans les traités et
c'est volontairement que les états
membres avaient créé une action commune
pour faire un groupement d'achat
mais ceci n'empêche pas les achats
nationaux justement sur cette
organisation européenne qui embauchent
mais on a du mal à y voir clair qui
décide de quoi finalement l'europe et
bien comme je viens de vous le dire les
traiter dans la compétence sanitaires
aux états donc a priori l'échelon
européen n'a pas de compétence
sanitaires mais bien entendu les états
peuvent décider d'un commun accord par
consensus de confier des actions
communes à la commission et c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour ce groupement
d'achat en commun de vaccins encore une
fois sans que ceux ci aient donne à la
commission un pouvoir exclusif d'acheter
les vaccins vers etam en garde leurs
compétences nationales et dans ce cadre
là
la commission a négocié sans doute dans
de mauvaises conditions
parce que acheter des vaccins c'est un
métier et je ne suis pas sûr qu'à la
commission il des acheteurs compétent
pour faire ce métier pour démarcher les
laboratoires les laboratoires ont
souscrit des contrats avec l'union
européenne mais aussi avec beaucoup de
pays du monde et probablement au promis
plus
vaccin qui n'était capable d'en
fabriquer alors dans ce cas là il ya une
solution très simple c'est que il y a
dans le monde des capacités
industrielles de fabrication de vaccins
et on a par exemple une en inde très
importante à laquelle beaucoup de
laboratoires occidentaux recours est
d'ailleurs astrazeneca vient de passer
un contrat pour que l'un d'eux fabrique
400 millions de doses de vaccins
astrazeneca
alors ensuite effectivement astrazeneca
décide ou commercialiser ces vaccins et
on voit comme c'est bizarre que l'un
d'eux dit mais puisque c'est sur mon
territoire
j'aimerais bien que ces vaccins profite
d'abord à la population indienne et que
ensuite et qui s'est exporté le
raisonnement que tient madame van riel
pour l'union européenne elle dit les
vaccins qui sont fabriqués sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
eh bien il faut qu'il ait d'abord aux
citoyens ressortissants l'union
européenne et qu'ensuite ils puissent
est exporté à l'extérieur par exemple en
grande-bretagne d'où le litige qui sera
aussi traitée par le conseil européen
jeudi et vendredi prochains je pense que
ça se terminera par un compromis
puisqu'il ya des capacités de production
ailleurs en inde par exemple ou bien
avec des ccit des cessions de droits
pour fabriquer le vaccin dans n'importe
quel pays de l'union européenne c'est le
cas l'italie déjà ça sera peut-être le
cas l'allemagne demain est par ailleurs
évidemment la possibilité de recourir
aux vaccins russe
et pourquoi pas aux vaccins chinois et
on attendra ça donc
lors de ce sommet on verra ça jeudi et
vendredi lors de ce sommet du conseil
européen merci à vous claude
blanchemaison nous avoir apporté votre
analyse
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de donald trump banny
vous le savez de twitter depuis janvier
l'ancien président américain va faire
son retour sur les réseaux sociaux d'ici
deux à trois mois avec je cite sa propre
plateforme
et puis direction le congo-brazzaville
l'élection présidentielle marqué par la
mort de guy brice parfait kolélas ce
décès des ducs au vide le soixantenaire
était considéré comme le principal rival
du président sortant
[Musique]
et
le maniement de la rumeur est vieux
comme le monde mais il est vrai que
l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux il va
donner une crédibilité destructrices
dans sa virtualité l'influencent a pris
toute sa place au coeur des
affrontements politiques et économiques
internationaux car elle est une
manifestation de la puissance capable de
peser sur l'évolution des situations
tous les jours nous entendons des
accusations de complotisme contre ceux
qui n'adhèrent pas à la pensée qu'on
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire vouloir
forcer le destin en récrivant une
histoire biaisée pour servir ses
intérêts ne tient pas dans la durée car
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez donald
trump bientôt de retour sur internet est
banni de tous les réseaux sociaux après
les évènements du capitole le 6 janvier
dernier l'ancien président américain qui
comptabilisait sur son compte twitter 88
millions d'abonnés annoncé par la boîte
ses conseillers qu'il préparait un
retour sur sa propre plateforme
plusieurs sociétés soir est en
pourparlers avec lui pour l'aider dans
sa démarche écoutez je pense que nous
allons voir le président trump de retour
sur les réseaux sociaux probablement
dans deux ou trois mois avec sa propre
plateforme
ce n'est pas seulement une société qui a
approché le président il y à de
nombreuses sociétés
cette nouvelle plateforme sera quelque
chose de gros tout le monde le veut il
va apporter des millions et des millions
des dizaines de millions d'abonnés à
cette nouvelle plateforme
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
de new york avec calais maupin
correspondant verte et aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir calais maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce soir
depuis les etats unis le conseiller donc
de donald trump ont bien de l'entendre
qui n'a pas souhaité fournir plus de
précisions quant on contours de cette
fameuse plateforme
à quoi doit-on s'attendre au surprenant
que donald trump souhaite étendre son
champ d'activité il a déjà des hôtels
des avions les universités dont il ne
doit pas être surprenant que donald
trump banni des grands réseaux sociaux
décident de lancer sa propre plateforme
une nouvelle aventure capitaliste que
donald trump lance sa propre forme cela
n'a rien de surprenant pour les soutiens
de donald trump
il est injustice il est injuste que
donald trump et de nombreuses voix
conservatrices et exclu des réseaux il
considère également que ces réseaux sont
piégées contre le ou les conservateurs
qu'il pourrait bien s'agir d'un gros
succès pour donald trump
ce retour sur un nouveau réseau social
c'est la victoire de la liberté
d'expression ou bien la défaite des
géants du numérique est un catcheur
exemple pour moi c'est un exemple du
fait que les géants du numérique sont de
plus en plus parce que gbagbo ait au
moins un autre cas site que la sitcom
valley ont longtemps essayé de maintenir
une apparence l'autralie t2
oui j'avais peur que les conservateurs
les incidents qui est facebook est
réduisent la part de marché qu'ils ont
essayé d'en maintenir cette apparence de
neutralité mais cela n'a pas fonctionné
et elle est conservateur aux états unis
se semble de plus en plus rejetée par
cette plateforme pour donald trump c'est
une occasion en or
lui-même a été ben ali de twitter de
facebook et il a dit il est donc temps
d'avancé alors l'ancien président on le
rappelle avec 88 millions d'abonnés sur
twitter
il y a des milliers des millions que des
gens de partisans aux etats-unis 1
quand on voit les vingt ans 75 millions
de votes pour trump ça représente une
manne très importante pour ce futur
réseau social et les états unis semble
étonnant car ce cours des quatre
dernières années nous avions des mises à
jour constantes des opinions et
sentiment du président un deal faisait
des commentaires sur le contexte
politique il inventait des surnoms et
tout d'un coup ils avaient disparu
donc effectivement donald trump cherche
un autre moyen de nous faire part de son
ressenti à la minute et avec son
bannissement de frites et de twitter il
ne pouvait plus le faire il décide donc
de se présentera au médium sa propre
plate forme pour continuer et est sans
doute que l'immense majorité à des
partisans de donald trump attendent avec
impatience d'entendre nouveau ses
pensées alors calmement par vous restez
avec mon s'il vous plaît dans quelques
instants nous allons parler avec vous de
l'afflux de migrants auxquels fait face
le gouvernement de joe biden depuis le
changement de politique migratoire
puisque le président américain fait face
à la première crise sérieuse depuis son
arrivée à la maison blanche
or coronavirus le président est accusé
d'être trop laxiste avec les migrants
qui passent la frontière
américano-mexicaine
ernement tente donc de rassurer sur sa
capacité à gérer ce délicat dossier est
la même et jane message est clair ne
venez pas sécurisé yuuwaa sous la
pression le secrétaire américain à la
sécurité intérieure a fait le tour des
médias ce dimanche
alejandro mayorkas ce lui-même fils de
réfugiés cubains est venu faire passer
un message
les candidats à l'immigration ne doivent
pas venir aux états unis des mots
martelés par joe biden quelques jours
auparavant accusé d'avoir provoqué
l'afflux de migrants à la frontière
américano-mexicaine le gouvernement
weiden tentent désormais de rectifier le
tir
le camp républicain mais aussi certains
démocrates reprochent au locataire de la
maison blanche d'avoir créé un appel
d'air
au delà de l'afflux de migrants le sort
des enfants isolés fait aussi polémique
je viens de quitter le centre de
traitement des frontières des centaines
d'enfants entassés dans de grandes
pièces ouvertes
j'ai retenu mes larmes alors qu'une
jeune fille de 13 ans sangloter de façon
incontrôlable en expliquant par
l'intermédiaire d'un traducteur
à quel point elle était terrifiée
d'avoir été séparé de sa grand-mère et
sans ses parents
les etats-unis sont au front tu es à une
arrivée sans précédent de mineurs isolés
ils sont aujourd'hui 15 milles sur le
territoire américain
un tiers de ces enfants sont retenus
parfois plus de dix jours dans des
centres destinés aux adultes
pourtant la loi américaine impose en
transit de 72 heures maximum pour ces
mineurs
avant un placement dans des familles
d'accueil de son côté donald trump n'a
pas hésité à s'engouffrer dans la brèche
tout ce qu'il y avait à faire c'était de
maintenir en mode pilote automatique un
système qui fonctionne bien
au lieu de cela en l'espace de quelques
semaines l'administration byden a
transformé un triomphe national en
désastre national
notre pays est en train d'être détruit à
la frontière sud
dès son arrivée à la maison blanche joe
biden a suspendu le financement du mur
prévus à la frontière
américano-mexicaine
au même moment le 46e président des
états unis a décidé d'appliquer un
moratoire de 100 jours sur les
expulsions de sans papiers est
d'admettre des demandeurs d'asile en
attente depuis plusieurs mois dans des
camps au mexique démesures vus comme un
feu vert par les candidats à
l'immigration les réseaux de passeurs
pour l'instant le gouvernement byden
refuse d'employer le terme de crise
migratoire
mais si la situation perdure le
président américain n'exclut pas à se
rendre prochainement à la frontière
mexicaine
oui nous sommes tous genres en direct
avec caleb maupin depuis les cieux de
berthet america 100000 un migrant fin
février soit on l'a entendu une
augmentation de 28% par rapport à
janvier on peut dire que wheldon a
ouvert les portes du pays et créer comme
on l'a vu une forme de crise migratoire
n'est pas comme ça c'est à l'hypocrisie
[Musique]
la présidence il y avait beaucoup et le
son dont l'orage dans les médias finale
3 essais de justin comme sauteur cruel
sadisme quelqu'un qui est emprisonné des
enfants il y avait une condamnation en
général de demain travers un temps que
pose du talent
cruel joe biden nous avons des centres
détention pour des enfants de grands
nous avons des enfants inscrits à la
passe la frontière des gens désespérés
crispante d'arriver aux états unis
plutôt que de le faire la morale les
médias traditionnels américains semblent
presque fait oublier ou souhait de
l'administration américaine et ne pas
diffuser ces images terribles de cette
prise est véritablement humanitaire il
ya des gens véritablement désespérée en
amérique du sud et du centre qui essaye
de passer aux états unis c'est le
résultat des politiques étrangères des
états unis qui avaient formé des
extrémistes des cartels pour lutter
contre le socialisme le communisme au
nicaragua honduras au guatemala
c'est cette politique le gouvernement
américain qui a encouragé le chaos afin
d'imposer le néolibéralisme de marché
mais qu'ils ont provoqué le cours par
exemple au honduras et beaucoup de
personnes dans ces régions n'ont pas
accès à l'eau courante à l'électricité
n'est pas le même pas l'espagnol met
toujours des langues indigènes
c'est le résultat des politiques
américaines et non ceux là on ignore
complètement sont astreints à jouer sur
la peur de me cran afin de flatter sa
base électorale
joe barton prétend être plus clément
plus d'humains mais la situation à la
même et les médias ont changé luc de ton
c'est cela le véritable sujet c'est
l'hypocrisie des médias comment réagir
l'opinion publique
justement va une sorte d' outrage très
sélectif lorsque donald trump heures
ils étaient des enfants dans les centres
les médias ont lancé une hystérie
collective contre le parti républicain
aujourd'hui ces mêmes forces face aux
mêmes politiques à de détention de
mineurs de centres de détention et bien
les médias comme le bénéfice du doute à
joe biden dix ans qui ne serait pas
correct de montrer des photos d'enfants
en cash dans l'immédiat c'est vraiment
l'hypocrisie du parti démocrate et il
n'y a aucune conversation sur aucune
discussion sur la racine de ce mal à la
racine et en a les politiques étrangères
américain et le commerce le libéral qui
a dévasté des régions entières
cette essayant de construire un système
capitaliste général universal et cela a
dévasté l'ohio la pennsylvanie le
guatemala et bien d'autres pays
donc on ne parle pas de la cause du mal
on condamne simplement ou morales les
républicains et on ferme les yeux
lorsque ce sont les démocrates au
pouvoir et alors qu'ils mènent a les
mêmes politiques le même capitalisme
universel
merci cas l'album hope un correspondant
d'arte et aux etats unis d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir pour vu de l'extérieur
merci à vous le congo brazzaville voté
hier pour la présidentielle un scrutin
marqué par le décès de guy brice parfait
kolélas s'est tendu qu'au vide
il est mort lors de son transfert
médicalisé vers la france il était
considéré comme le principal rival au
président sortant denis sassou nguesso
au pouvoir depuis près de trente sept
ans et qui brigue un quatrième mandat du
maroussi
une élection boudé par les congolais ils
étaient peu nombreux ce dimanche à
s'être déplacés pour choisir le prochain
président de la république dans certains
bureaux de vote le taux de participation
atteignait à peine les 10 % à la
fermeture une abstention qui n'a pas
empêché le président denis sassou
n'guesso de se féliciter du processus
électoral
jusque
suis dit que
ainsi qu'ils ne se présente pas
c'est un bond simple pourtant plusieurs
irrégularités ont bel et bien été
constaté à brazzaville les représentants
du parti congolais du travail au pouvoir
était souvent les seuls délégués
politiques présents dans les bureaux de
vote des électeurs se sont également
plaints de ne pas voir leur nom figurer
sur les listes électorales d'autres
n'ont tout simplement pas reçu leur
carte d'électeur des irrégularités
dénoncées par les candidats de
l'opposition
mes impressions dans ce but le voyais a
pas beaucoup de gens qui viennent
et elle sait pas pourquoi ça traîne est
due aux conditions moi la bise le
secteur j'ai constaté que dans là tout
le secteur les gens n'ont pas eu des cas
d'électeurs une opposition dont le
meilleur espoir vient de s'éteindre
diagnostiqué vendredi positif au
coronavirus guy brice parfait kolélas ce
est décédé à bord de l'avion médicalisé
qui l'évacuer vers la france avant sa
mort il avait appelé ses sympathisants à
voter en masse
je suis convaincu
[Musique]
bien sûr une difficulté sur mon bac
entre l'amour mais cependant je vous
demande de vous lever
allez-y voté pour le changement
je me serais pas battu pour rien battez
vous et les vagues de la venue de pau
centre
mas dieu merci
les premiers résultats du scrutin ne
devraient être connus que dans le
courant de la semaine
en attendant le réseau internet a été
coupé dans tout le pays
aucun incident n'a été déploré le
maintien au pouvoir de denis sassou
n'guesso devrait lui être assurée après
déjà trente six années à la tête de
l'état congolais en 2016 sa réélection
contestée avait entraîné une violente
révolte dans le sud est du pays et pour
en parler nous sommes nous avec alfred
shango maître de conférences à la
sorbonne nouvelle bonsoir apprécions vos
merci d'être avec nous l'hybris connais
la parfait kolélas sans l'opposant qui
avait été testée positive vendredi
tout est allé très vite on a vu ces
images on imagine que le pays est sous
le choc
tout à fait je touche les leçons des
villages le testament politique que guy
brice parfait kolélas fils t'enlève sol
congolais
et puis l'air il faut se battre pour
conquérir de droit il faut se loger se
battre pour conquérir ce droit et en
australie
il les appelait à la ferme il en a les
fautifs que les changements la mort
l'enquêté mais le message bref il y en a
ils portaient que lui pour sa famille
pour cent partis politiques et pour le
peuple congolais
on imagine que ce message va
probablement être entendu parce que tout
de même il avait réussi plus ou moins
fédérer derrière lui une partie de
l'opposition
son décès c'est un coup dur pour la
tendance politique
oui c'est un coup moi très dur pour
l'opposition ou très dur pour
l'alternance évidemment
personne n'était dupe les huiles et les
autres membres de l'opposition que
c'étaient les champs allait changer la
donne politique de brazzaville où la
juge que certains candidats n'ont pas
même s'ils n'ont même pas pu battre
campagne comics joie faute de moyens que
c'était très inégale par rapport à delhi
se lever tôt et que donc il fallait
effectivement cher jouer le jeu
démocratique a jusqu'au bout c'est ce
que c'est ce qu'ils ont fait on a testé
en particulier si brice parfait kolélas
si on comprend bien finalement denis
sassou nguesso est en bonne place pour
partir pour un énième mandat
ben tout a été fait tout est fait pour
justement que il conquiert un quatrième
mandat
l'un d'eux parce que nous restons
attachés à aucun doute a d'ailleurs le
peuple congolais a manifesté une femme
de l'attitude charte mais justement et
systèmes 6e neurones qu'il se renouvelle
pas et on agit lui pas des par exemple
refusé de participer à ces élections
puis pas d effet l'ancien parti le parti
de l'ancien président pascal lissouba a
refusé d'aller aux élections parce
qu'elle considérait que c'était joué
dans avance que les détecter qu'à cela
ne tienne effectivement on va encore
avoir des lits fassions des sceaux pour
un mandat de cinq ans encore et ça pose
une énorme question au peuple congolais
mais surtout à l'opposition congolaise
de savoir comment elle va s'en sortir
avec cette énième défaite en championnat
à l'élection présidentielle et il
faudrait cesser la structure de toute
manière alors on précise que les
observateurs des nations unies et de
l'union européenne n'ont pas été invités
à surveiller
l'élection que disent les pays
occidentaux sur cette probable
réélection sans surprise et l'absence a
priori de renouvellement démocratique au
congo pour le moment le silence
assourdissant en particulier de la
france
layton n'aime pas le fait que personne
au niveau de l'union européenne
de ce fait d'illusions sur le résultat
ya une personne qui posait une question
a fait malicieuse du genre au lancement
d'une europe et l on entend la france
comme c'est par exemple venezuela tantôt
santelli à crier haut et fort à la
fronde mais quand il s'agit du congo
ouvrage agile on les entend moins
et là les observateurs qui ont été au
congo de l'afrique
évidemment le poste à qu'on peut dire ce
que le gouvernement du vieux con g zoumi
les propos de denis sassou n'guesso qui
s'est satisfait qui se contentent
justement de la manière dont les choses
elle les élections l'élection
présidentielle a été organisée mais on
l'a vu ce qu'ils ont dans leur qui a
beaucoup de lacunes dans l'organisation
merci alfred shango maître de
conférences à la sorbonne nouvelle
d'avoir été avec nous
dans le reste de l'actualité retour en
france où le procès en appel de la
banque privée suisse ubs reprend ce
lundi jusqu'au 24 mars ubs est accusé
d'avoir orchestré un système d'évasion
fiscale aujourd'hui les lanceurs
d'alertés ancien employé de la banque
dénonce également lé lien qu'aurait
entretenue cette dernière avec des
personnalités et des politiques nous les
avons rencontrés un sujet signé katia
pique nique la sphère ubs est rejugé en
appel jusqu'au 24 mars à paris la plus
grande banque privée suisse avait été
condamné à payer l'amendé record de 4,5
milliards d'euros pour démarchage
illégal et blanchiment aggravé de fraude
fiscale au détriment de l'état français
l'accusation dénonce un gigantesque
système d'évasion fiscale qui encouragé
les clients français à transférer leurs
actifs sur des comptes non déclarés en
suisse
au procès les anciens directeurs ou
cadres de la banque se défendent de
toute action illégale des arguments
réfutés par bradley birkenfeld ancien
gérant de fortune chez ubs aux états
unis en 2006 il s'est fait connaître
pour ses révélations de pratiques
frauduleuses de la banque privée
le scandale qu'il a soulevés a mené à
l'interdiction du secret bancaire suisse
en 2009
cela ne lui a pas évité une condamnation
à trente mois de prison pour fraude
fiscale toujours en 2009 mais il a
ensuite reçu 104 millions de dollars du
fisc américain pour ses confessions pour
lui la banque suisse en serait
finalement tirer à bon compte aux états
unis en échappant au procès et en
écopant que d'une faible amende
grâce à ses appuis politiques barack
obama a reçu de l'argent du ps pour sa
campagne
yara clinton a reçu de l'argent pour sa
fondation de la part du ps et du
gouvernement suisse et bill clinton a
signé des contrats pour des conférences
pour ubs pour des millions de dollars
alors vous pensez qu'ils vont se ranger
de quel côté ubs ou bras dire qu'elle
fait là
hillary clinton avait beaucoup de
donneurs parce que je connais beaucoup
de clients qui donnait pour sa campagne
depuis la suisse donc c'est une
corruption supplémentaires qui explique
pourquoi ils n'ont pas voulu poursuivre
ubs en bonne et due forme et documents
internes à l'appui il livre son
interprétation de la stratégie mondiale
de la banque suisse il y avait un
programme d'hier et ferrals qui
reportait les clients du marché onshore
soit légale au marché offshore de suisse
pourquoi 1 parce que leur jeu est resté
plus longtemps
2 il facturait des frais plus important
il pensait pouvoir leur assurer le
secret je sais cela car les banquiers
recevez un bonus alors ce qui se passe
c'est que vous rémunérer des banquiers
ce qui est du blanchiment d'argent en
réalité car vous participez un système
d'évasion fiscale ce qui mène au
blanchiment d'argent et à d'autres actes
délictueux ubs suisse serait t'il aussi
l'aspirateur du bs france parmi les
ténors du barreau qui défendent la
banque denis chemla à proposer cette
même hypothèse pour mieux la réfuter
patrick de faille est l'ancien numéro 2
du ps france s'est aussitôt défendu de
toute stratégie pour siphonner les
comptes hexagonaux selon lui sa mission
était de développer la jeune banque
française stéphanie gibeau ancien chargé
du marketing du bs france entre 1999 et
finalement licencié par la banque en
2012 conteste en alimentant le service
national des douanes judiciaires en 2011
et 2012 avec des documents qui lui a été
demandé de faire fuiter
la lanceuse d' alerte a fourni la
matière de l'accusation
aujourd'hui abandonnée de tous y compris
de l'état français qu'elle a abondamment
servi
elle n'est pas le citer à comparaître à
l'audience aucun lanceur d' alerte à la
barre stéphane djibo a son avis sur la
question
ubs gère les fortunes de tous nos
dirigeants économiques financiers
médiatiques politiques partout dans le
monde ici inclus et là j'en suis une
témoins privilégiés puisque pendant
douze ans j'ai organisé des centaines
d'événements pour la banque où toutes
les familles les plus fortunées de
france étaient présentes soit des gens
du show business des sportifs de haut
niveau des hommes politiques bien
évidemment des juges mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas le nom affiché de
ces personnes qui fraudent pourquoi
est-ce que tout est caché
pourquoi est ce que la justice française
ne peut pas exploiter cette liste
pourquoi des gens comme moi justement
sont dans la situation qu'on va
l'expliquer c'est à dire ne pas être
entendu par la justice alors que là
où serait le témoin clé de cette justice
puisque j'ai travaillé pour l'état
français pendant plus d'un an
alors qui sont ces fameux nom des
détenteurs de comptes
le journaliste antoine peillon et le
lanceur d'alert nicolas forissier ancien
responsable d'audit de la banque ubs
les évoque dans un entretien explosif
mise en ligne le 17 mars
nicolas forissier a visé entre autres
les comptes ubs de l'héritière de
l'oréal liliane bettencourt
il explique qu'il avait repéré entre fin
2005 et 2007 en pleine campagne
présidentielle de nicolas sarkozy
des opérations pour 20 millions d'euros
ne faisant l'objet d'aucune vérification
légale en termes de lutte contre le
blanchiment
à partir de novembre 2017 on retrouve
d'ailleurs aux manettes de la gestion de
fortune de liliane bettencourt patrick
de maistre et florence woerth la femme
d'eric woerth
le trésorier de l'ump et ministre du
budget de nicolas sarkozy dès 2009 la
dcr y alors sous la direction de bernard
squarcini reçoit des notes sur la
découverte d'un système d'évasion
fiscale au sein du ps et l'incroyable se
produit nicolas forissier et placés sous
surveillance et un agent en enquêtant
sur ubs a là des séries et sommé
d'arrêter les notes sur la fraude ne
sont même pas transmises au procureur un
véritable scandale que dénonce en 2013
un collectif d'officiers de la dcn i
dans un rapport
pourquoi après avoir découvert cette
infraction pénale
la sous-direction cas de la dessert qui
ne l'at-elle pas dénoncés au procureur
de la république
pourquoi la sous-direction cas at-elle
axé son travail de surveillance sur les
cadres de l'ubs et s qui dénonçait le
système de fraude plutôt que sur ce qui
était à l'origine du système
le lanceur d'alert pense que le service
de renseignement voulait savoir s'il
détenait la preuve ultime d'un
financement de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
le journaliste d'investigation antoine
peillon qui enquêtait des années sur ubs
livre son hypothèse
certains gros clients auraient été des
financeurs occulte de campagne
électorale de grandes personnalités
politiques françaises politique qui
était au pouvoir et aurait
instrumentalisé les services de
renseignements intérieurs pour protéger
l'évasion fiscale de ces grands
donateurs
il n'y a pas de preuve formelle mais de
nombreux documents et indices
concordants
on se souvient qu'en 2012 eric woerth
avait été soupçonné d'avoir recueilli
des dizaines de milliers d'euros en
liquide provenant de liliane bettencourt
mise en examen pour trafic d'influencé
passif et recel
il a bénéficié d'un non lieu en 2015 sa
connaissance de l'origine des fonds et
de la vulnérabilité de madame
bettencourt n'avait pas pu être démontré
rt france a demandé des interviews à
plusieurs avocats du bs qui ont tous
décliné ou n'ont pas donné suite aux
sollicitations
ce retour de l' affaire ubs dans
l'actualité sera-t-il l'occasion de
mettre en lumière un nouveau scandale
d'état
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point complet
sur l'actualité dans quelques minutes
avec pierre saby hivernaux quant à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20 heures
d
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est